welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to the cursive layer on that is
finally upon us with the film's release
assuring in a new legend to the big
screen throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the movie its tie-in to
the conjuring and its ending this is
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
to know anything about the film then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I hope you enjoy the
video now sit back relax and let's get
into my ending explain breakdown of the
curse of La Llorona okay so the first
thing that you need to know about the
curse of lair owner is that it actually
takes place in the cultural universe in
between the conjuring and the conjuring
to this they'll never publicly confirmed
was teased throughout the marketing of
the movie and it's finally cemented in
the film itself whilst Italian isn't
massive it comes in the form of a
recurring character that appears both in
this film and Annabelle from 2016
initially the film's main character and
I goes to father Perez for more
information on La Llorona and later she
asks for his aid when she realizes that
her own children are a danger the priest
tells Ana that it's not the first time
he's dealt with an evil presence which
of course is non other than Annabelle
unfortunately Perez is unable to help
Ana as he must receive permission from
his peers this is time that Ana doesn't
have and therefore outside of a couple
bits of exposition the character is
pretty useless undistorted too owns a
Raggedy Ann doll which if you didn't
know is what the actual Anabel is in
real life so this is a nice little
easter egg nod towards that and those
are the two big tie-ins which are
slightly disappointing and probably one
of the main reasons that this hasn't
been advertised as part of the universe
this could also be because there's
another conjuring film coming out later
this year and the studio don't really
want to seem like there's going to be an
MCU load of these in case people get
franchise fatigue though no official
statement has been released yet the film
itself takes place in LA during the
1970s and follows a social worker and
the children who are drawn into a
supernatural realm after ignoring the
warning of a troubled mother we follow
annotate Garcia
worker who at the witnessing a
distressing case of child abuse comes to
discover that there is far more going on
than bad parenting one of the biggest
criticisms that I've seen about the film
is that it trivializes child abuse as a
plot device and if you're sensitive to
that sort of thing then the movie might
not be for you as it pretty much blamed
some cases on evil spirits so who is
this evil spirit anyway and why is she
after children well throughout the film
we learn that layer on a drowned her
children after she discovered that her
husband wasn't faithful and due to the
guilt killed herself
this murder-suicide has cursed her soul
to home for the children as she becomes
fixated on them and believes that they
are her own unfortunately Patricia
attempted to bargain with Leona and
prayed to her in an attempt to pass on
the curse to Ana's children in the hopes
of revenge much in the same way that the
spirit herself seeks it thus the spirit
descends on Ana's house hoping to get
her children there's a lot of
back-and-forth with a family attempting
to get her out of the house and Ana
seeks the help of a spiritual faith
healer known as Rafael with his help and
about 70 jump scares because 14
year-olds love that kind of thing the
family are able to find a way to defeat
the weeping woman by the film's close
they managed to exorcise her from the
property using sanctify tears and at the
seeds of the fire tree which she is
vulnerable to is since they were present
when she killed their children the
family and Rafael managed to create a
mystical barrier that will apparently
block her unfortunately Ana's daughter
is a bit of an idiot and sees one of
their dolls outside and when rushing to
get it breaks the barrier which forces
the family to go toe-to-toe with the
entity and they attempt to hide the
children from the vengeful ghost
eventually the family retreat to the
attic and lay aronia believing that the
children are hers are manifest in human
form so that she can kill them at this
point
Rafael steps forward and using a cross
that is made of wood from the fire tree
he and Ana are able to finally vanquish
her it's a bit similar to the blood of
Christ plot device that was used in the
nun but here I feel it works a hell of a
lot better and
Retta bear unlike most films from the
franchise the curse of La Llorona
actually has a more hopeful ending with
the family managing to actually put her
to rest though she may return in the
peach year and I actually think she will
be present in Annabelle comes home which
is due out later this year in that film
many of the spirits that the Warrens
have encountered over the years are said
to be returning so it would make a lot
of sense to bring their latest horror
personality into the bold those who've
seen the curse of Leia run out we'll
know when she comes on-screen that she
really makes an impact and I can
definitely see them reliving the scares
from this film especially as the Warrens
have children themselves we of course
will find out later in the year but it
will be interesting to see if the studio
resurrect Slayer on app for the film
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the curse of Lana Del Rey sorry about
that and if you think that she will make
another appearance sorry if I butchered
a name a bit
I think the films being called the curse
of the weeping woman in some markets
because people like myself are terrible
at reading things so yeah sorry I'm an
idiot but give me a thumbs up if I got
it right at least once leave your review
on the film in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video and like spoilers
then make sure you check out my
breakdown of the leaked footage of a
benches and game which would be linked
at the end this is the channel for
people who were mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]